whatever the reason a character's
departing expression
says a lot about who they were and the
stories in which they played their final
roles
whether disturbing beautiful or
something else altogether
these dying smiles cemented the legacies
of the characters who offered them
inside out famously left audiences of
all ages in tears
the story centers around a young girl
named riley who's struggling to adjust
after a big move
she's in the midst of new and
increasingly complicated feelings that
come with getting older and inside her
head the personifications of joy and
sadness are on a quest to restore
some semblance of order they eventually
meet bing bong
riley's childhood imaginary friend
excuse me
uh i was i was looking for um diversion
sucker as the trio tries to heal the
emotional wounds that threaten to
overwhelm riley
joy and bing bong end up in the memory
dump a canyon of forgotten memories that
are eventually erased forever
desperate the two try to escape on bing
bong's wagon which propels itself with
rainbows and
is fueled by song and belief joy and
bingbong take care of the singing but
riley has lost touch with her faith and
imagination and the wagon can't make it
to the top
bing bong realizes that without his
weight the wagon will go the distance
and he sacrifices himself
this means that riley will forget about
him but as joy flies to freedom he
smiles because he knows riley will grow
up with the emotional health to make
so many more wonderful memories
take her to the moon for me okay
tim burton's films are often dark but
they all have his trademark whimsical
humor
the combination is often surreal and his
1989 take on batman
is no exception right down to the death
of the joker
the fusion of gothic sensibilities with
a certain sense of wonder feels just a
little demented
making burton's filmmaking style a great
medium through which to portray this
particular villain
speaking of gothic the joker dies on the
steps of a cathedral after batman
tethers him to a gargoyle that later
plummets to the ground
before his demise he dances happily
while waiting for his getaway helicopter
of course he takes the moment to gloat
and laugh at batman and vicki vale
the joke's on him however it's his own
helicopter that tugs him and the
gargoyle free from the ledge so he truly
is responsible for his own death
but even in his final moments he remains
psychotic and smiling
like he's the only one who understands
the punchline
the princess bride introduced audiences
to a conniving villain by the name of
vizzini
a genius level thug who kidnaps princess
buttercup and draws the ire of the dread
pirate roberts
a buccaneer who secretly buttercups long
lost lover wesley
when wesley catches up with the
kidnapper the two have an odd challenge
in mind to decide things once and for
all
wesley and vizzini engage in a battle of
wits in which the latter must choose
between two goblets knowing one is
poisoned
the zeni has a trick up his sleeve
though what in the world can that be
what where i don't see anything
he switches the goblets when wesley's
back is turned thinking he has tricked
his enemy in reality wesley has prepared
for this moment by poisoning himself for
so long that he's become immune to the
toxin
as it turns out he's contaminated both
cups as smart as vasini thinks he is he
never would have imagined that his enemy
would poison himself
he dies laughing reveling in his
perceived triumph with no idea that it
was the body not the mind that would
decide this battle
inconceivable titanic introduced us to
the king of the world himself
jack dawson he's a working class rogue
who falls for the aristocratic rose and
by the end of the film he's totally
stolen her heart
however when the titular ship crashes
into that iceberg it sends our
lovestruck heroes plummeting into the
ocean leading to a frosty finale
as rose floats above the water on a
wooden door jack is half submerged at
her side
there's apparently nothing else for him
to grab onto and jack pleads with rose
to never give up
you're gonna get out of here you're
gonna go on
and you're gonna make lots of babies if
she can just stay afloat help will come
leading to happiness even after he's
gone jack then falls unconscious due to
hypothermia and never wakes up but one
of the last things he does before dying
is smile at the woman he loves some say
you see your life flash before your eyes
in your last moments but it seems like
jack saw roses instead
smiles that precede sacrifice often come
from recognizing a bigger cause than
one's own survival
steve trevor's final sacrifice saves the
love of his life and all of humanity
so that's a big win for him his love is
the titular hero of 2017's wonder woman
who tasks herself with confronting ares
the god of war threatens to destroy
humanity with world war one and this
includes manipulating an evil scientist
who's engineered a new form of mustard
gas
in his final sacrifice steve flies a
plane containing this poison to a safe
altitude before it's scheduled to
detonate destroying the poison and
himself
in the process he offers up his own life
because he loves her but he also
demonstrates a love for all of humanity
steve became concrete proof of what she
doubted that humans have goodness and
love in them
and are therefore worth saving steve
smiled in the end because he knew he had
given love a second chance to prevail
it has to be me it has to be me
i can save today you could save the
world
despite giving his film the title of
kill bill volume 2 writer director
quentin tarantino kept audiences
guessing as to whether beatrix the bride
kiddo would take her former lover and
long time enemy to meet his maker for
the massacre he committed at her wedding
when she finally vanquishes him he
smiles after she delivers the final blow
and he has many reasons he's made peace
with her
he has a daughter he's mourned beatrix
then tried to kill her and is now dying
at her hands
the ending is as poetic as each deserves
bill isn't the only one who greets his
death with a degree of good humor
beatrix does as well even if it's
artificial bill didn't want her daughter
to see her in tears so when she mourns
him the next day her tears are mixed
with
uncontrollable laughter bill knew or
perhaps hoped
that she would need to cry because she
still loved him and perhaps this is the
ultimate reason for his dying smile
it makes a lot of sense that the green
miles john coffey a savior figure who
shares the initials and miraculous
healing abilities of jesus christ would
have an
uncommon take on death his expression is
strained as he waits wrongly convicted
in the electric chair to be executed
but it definitely looks like a smile the
most striking aspect of jon's death was
that he chose to die
the dark side to his supernatural
healing abilities was the constant pain
he felt as an intimate witness to the
cruelty of humanity
john spent his time on earth lifting
this burden from others but in choosing
with his death to reveal the cruelty of
the world he shared the burden with paul
edgcum
we can imagine that jon smiled with
relief of a weight finally lifted and
maybe even some hope that humanity might
learn to share its burdens and heal
itself
people often find themselves smiling
when embarking on a new adventure and
albus dumbledore described death as the
next great adventure
when his on-screen end came in harry
potter and the half-blood prince he was
ready
his smile was that of a conspirator
playing everyone like fiddles
he'd accepted his death long ago when he
was irreversibly infected by a cursed
ring
he knew he had to die and if it happened
by severus snape's hand voldemort would
trust snape who could then protect harry
from behind enemy lines
dumbledore smiled because he knew harry
was still on the road to fulfilling his
destiny
additionally by asking snape to do the
deed both wizards spared draco from the
heinous act that would undoubtedly
propel him past the point of no
return leaving the misguided boy with
hope for redemption most of all
dumbledore knew his death would be his
greatest service to the wizarding world
the theory behind obi-wan kenobi's
pre-mortem smile the one just before
darth vader's killing blow in star wars
episode 4 a new hope
has developed over the course of future
revelations in the franchise
eventually we realized that obi-wan knew
the true parentage of luke and leia
even if the nature of the relationship
was decided after the 1977 film
premiered
help me obi-wan kenobi you're my only
hope
what's this what is what he asked you a
question what is that
originally it seemed like he could have
smiled because he was about to commune
with the force or because he knew luke
would escape along with the hope of
defeating the empire
but considering the information acquired
from subsequent films it could be
imagined that his smile had to do with
luke and leia being reunited
more than just a heartwarming moment for
the skywalker family luke and leia's
reunion represented the idea that
neither time nor
distance nor any other seemingly
indomitable force
not even the force was more powerful
than love
it feels so good to finally get a joke
just ask mr dawes senior from the
original mary poppins
the elder dawes is a classic greedy boss
and just before he dies he chides
employee george banks for using the word
supercalifragilisticexpialidocious
george asks him if he'd like to hear a
joke which goes there were these
two wonderful young people jane and
michael and they meet one day on the
street and jane says to michael i know a
man with a wooden leg named smith
and michael says really what's the name
of his other leg
dawes at first thinks that george has
gone mad not yet understanding the joke
he repeats the punchline over and over
to himself until he finally gets it
and then he begins laughing
uncontrollably before floating into the
air
he eventually dies of laughter which
george regrets upon finding out but the
greedy old man's son assures george that
he'd never seen his father happier
the ending of donnie darko is
notoriously confusing
the title character in this film dies
laughing finally finding peace and
relief in a cosmic role that has eluded
him throughout his life
this role befalls him by chance an
unspecified disruption creates a tangent
universe
which is a duplicate of the primary
universe in every way except for one
anomaly
a jet engine which is duplicated twice
with no logical place in the tangent
universe the extra copy happens to fall
on donny's house
donny likely because he happened to be
at the center of the tangent universe's
genesis
is chosen to guide the anomaly out of
that universe to safely
collapse the timeline the only way to do
so is to send it through a portal to the
primary universe where it falls onto
donny's house as well
this time with him inside
likely finds comfort in the fact that he
was right about this tangent universe
and not crazy
at least not in the way that everyone
told him he was
he also probably smiled shortly before
death because by stabilizing the
timelines he saved the people he loved
independence day was a huge hit with
audiences in 1996
partly because of a colorful ensemble of
characters that included retired pilot
russell case an alien abductee who
volunteers to confront an alien warship
attacking
area 51. eventually russell is the only
pilot with a missile available to
compromise the warship's weapons port
but
it malfunctions russell recognizes that
he can complete his mission by piloting
his craft
directly into its target which will kill
him in the process he tells his
compatriots to give his love to his
family then crashes into the warship
with a grin and a gleeful shout
out
in the end the most important thing for
russell was the safety of his family as
well as a little revenge against the
aliens who abducted him
his final moments were filled with the
kind of purpose that creates a legend
and enough adrenaline to follow through
on that purpose with a smile
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you